american citizens are threatened
by the loss of their middle class
by the loss of their sovereign borders
and especially from elites of
administrative state and globalism that
would surrender our sovereignty to an
unknown body of world experts or
technocrats
[Music]
there are two million people scheduled
to cross the borders of the united
states between mexico and america none
of them are going to enter legally no
vaccinations for colgan there's going to
be no test for covet solely for the
purpose
of enhancing the progressive agenda and
the democratic party we have no border
and there is no immigration law if we
look more importantly at the middle
class we are emerging from a pandemic a
population emerging from quarantine an
already inflationary cycle where we were
not producing goods and services because
of the quarantine or the population was
not growing at a vast rate that would
justify printing more money and yet
that's what we're doing and the result
of it is for the first time in 30 years
we have an annual inflation rate of
somewhere between four and a half to
seven percent once interest rates go up
people will not be able to pay for these
inflationary prices for cars or major
appliances or home they'll stop buying
and then we'll have a recession we're
also in the middle of something i don't
think any american has ever seen before
and that is a new woke movement what
wokeness says is according to one of its
architects professor kendy and to the
creators of the black lives matter
movement is simply this because of
discrimination in the history of the
united states it really can't be saved
as professor kendy said to stop
discrimination you've got to
discriminate we now have to discriminate
by promoting people on the color of
their skin in proportions that are
larger than their percentages of the
population as i speak we have people in
confinement who
are apparently charged with organizing a
riot or an armed insurrection the media
told us that the investigatory bodies
told us that the biden administration
told us that but here's the problem no
one has been charged with conspiracy no
one has been charged with racketeering
no one has been charged with organizing
an insurrection because it was not an
insurrection as the fbi has recently
found so what am i getting at i'm
getting out the equal applicability of
the law and the administrative state's
execution
we had a hundred and twenty day riot
that had just finished
and that was the summer of 2020. in 120
days of rioting a federal courthouse was
torched a police precinct was torched
with policemen inside it a historic
saint john's episcopal church right
across from the white house was torched
if anything it was called a legitimate
protest against the trump administration
it was much
differently portrayed in the press and
by the administrative state we've got to
remember that
there is an agenda
an international cosmopolitan agenda by
very wealthy people very sophisticated
people very educated people and that's
something called the great reset
klaus schwab
the architect of the davos group who
discovered created inaugurated the idea
that all of the world's luminaries
the best
captains of industry
the best silicon valley architects of
the internet social media
the most impressive military leaders the
most impressive politicians they could
all assemble at davos switzerland among
friends
even though they were of different
countries they all were so enlightened
that they could agree that the world was
getting too hot
and there had to be an international
body that overrode
legislatures or dictators or theocrats
or democracies or republics this group
now is
very earnestly trying to fan out through
their respective countries
to
harmonize all of
the nations of the world to turn over
their
sovereignty to the select group in terms
of globalization the covet 19 pandemic
has been an opportunity
for globalists to
suggest that we need more centralized
international and global power we have a
lot of politicians who feel that under
the cloak
of fear
and national quarantines and lockdowns
that they can change the system and
therefore governor newsome in california
said that
perhaps during the covert pandemic we
can have a more progressive form of
capitalism in the manner that klaus
schwab said hillary clinton said perhaps
during the covet lockdown it's an
opportunity to get a single health payer
or more ambitious government health care
plan i think it was jane fonda the
actress and occasional
davos attendee who said thank god for
the virus because it was a mechanism to
get rid of donald trump we've outlined
all of the challenges to traditional
citizenship but one thing is
pretty clear that a majority of
americans
respect and want to keep the
constitution as it is and they feel that
they're the luckiest people in the world
because they're american citizens as
long as we remain the majority of
americans
and remain vigilant
the power under our system is in our
hands
you